hey what's up this is international
master Schoology here with another
lesson on tactical signals
this one's on a Manuel Neiman's fourth
signal the night fork the night is
difficult to master because it doesn't
move in straight lines like the other
pieces so first before we look at any
practical examples we're going to look
at some general things you need to learn
about the night these are the night's
blind spots it would take the night for
moves to reach one of them a blind spot
is two squares diagonally from the night
so if the nights on c2 then a four and E
4 are its blind spots putting a rook or
a queen on one of these squares could
severely limit your opponent's night all
right so if the nights on e7 what are
its blind spots g5 and c5 if you cannot
get on one of these squares and you have
to get up close to the night then stay
on a vertical or horizontal square it'll
take the night three moves to get to one
of these squares now if you only need to
worry about two pieces getting forked
then what you can do is keep your pieces
on opposite colored squares for example
white doesn't have a chance at forking
blacks King and Bishop because black can
just keep his pieces on different
colored squares and he'll always avoid
the fork like that those are some basic
tips on avoiding the knight fork but if
you want to learn how to dominate the
knight then you have to practice moving
it so what you can do is you can put a
knight on any random square and then
pick another random square and calculate
how many moves it would take the knight
to get there and call out the route you
had in mind for example if the Knights
on g6 and you simply call out c3 as the
destination square then you can say
three because it would take three moves
to get
they're f4d 5c3 you call it the number
of moves it would take to get there and
the route now if you want you can call
out other routes that's that's totally
fine for example here I could send f-4e
to c3 or eise Evan d5 c3 etc etc and you
can add pawns in on random squares and
avoid the squares where you can be taken
so this is another example let's say my
nights on g5 and the destination square
is c7 so I would say 4 because it would
take 4 moves to get there and then I
would call out a route I would call out
the route efore c-5a 6 c7 so do this a
lot so you can become proficient and
moving the night this position comes
from the Blitz game between Alexey Dre
ov and Dimitri and Dracon white Windsor
rook thanks to the alignment of the
bishop and the Queen but it's not yet
resigning because black has compensation
in the form of white sweet King remember
my lesson on King position uh-huh
black plays h5 and that still mates the
white king remember my lesson on King
position at this point why it should be
looking out for tactics according to my
advice but he played the reckless Queen
d3 what he should have played is queen
c8 followed by rook D for giving back
some of the material with the idea of
drawing the Queen or the night away from
from White's King so back to the game
black to play pause the video and find
the knight fork ready Queen h1 and why
it's got no choice but to interpose with
the bishop because the King is still
made it's the King doesn't have any
legal moves now after Bishop h2 Knight
f4 forks the king and the Queen so black
used white sweet King position and an
alignment
to make the night for quark this
position comes from the classical game
between chakra our mama D Aarav and
Sammy Joker White's totally winning
because he's up a piece but black is
generating a threat so it's not yet
resigning black spinning the knight on
e6 to the unprotected bishop on g4 and
attacking it twice so you'd think the
best move would be to give back some
material with rook d7 and then something
like f4 with the idea of f5 turning East
6 into an outpost but mammoth Yara finds
a better solution to stay up a full
piece because he wants to maintain all
of his material advantage he doesn't
want to give anything back because what
he notices is that there are a lot of
signals in White's favor blacks King
position is shaky the bishop on d7 is
poorly protected the rook on h8 is
totally unprotected and there are
alignments all over the place from
blacks point of view this is a pin but
from White's point of view it's a
potential discovery White's rook and
Bishop converge upon the d7 square
White's rook aligns with blacks
unprotected h8 rook which means that the
h7 pawn is pinned and on the seventh
rank blacks got a few pieces lined up so
mom and Yara takes advantage of all
these signals pause the video and find
the best move for white ready Knight f8
when I was going over the game I was
like huh and then I was like ah that's
nice
whites for King d7 and g6 White's
attacking d7 three times and it's only
being defended twice and white tonight
also threatens to take on g6 which Forks
the King on e7 and the rook on h8 of
course that wouldn't be possible without
the favourable alignment white has on
the H file now if black plays King f8
then why it takes on d7 and goes into a
simplified endgame up
peace if black plays rook f 8 then rook
H 7 exploits the alignment of blacks
pieces on the seventh rank so for
example rook of seven rook F seven King
F seven and rook d7 once again whites in
a simplified endgame up a piece in the
game choker play Bishop g4 and white
Forge blacks king and rook with Knight
g6 the game ended after King e6 and f3
why does a little switcheroo he wins the
G for Bishop because it's trapped it's
got nowhere to go
for example rook g8 Knight h4 and
White's ready to take the bishop on the
next move so that has to do with the
signal of trapped pieces that's the next
lesson in this series and that's it for
name ins forth signal the knight fork
remember to use the tips I gave you at
the beginning of the lesson they're
simple and useful and also remember that
night Forks rarely fall from the sky out
of nowhere they're mostly accompanied by
other signals
alright guys follow me on twitter at
scuola G and I'll see you on chest comm
bye